Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
En tant que neuroscientifique,
il y a une question
qui me fascine et qui m’effraie.
Qu’est-ce qu’une banane ?
C'est une vraie question.
Une banane, c’est jaune, c’est courbé,
ça s’épluche à la main,
avec sa peau épaisse,
et ça se mange avec du Nutella.
Et c’est ça, une banane,
pour un neuroscientifique,
Ce sont les neurones de la couleur jaune,
les neurones de la forme courbée,
les neurones de la sensation
d’éplucher la peau,
et les neurones du goût du Nutella
qui s’activent dans notre cerveau.
On a tous et toutes
une banane dans le cerveau.
Maintenant, deuxième question:
cette banane existe-t-elle ?
Eh bien, vous n’avez aucun moyen
de le savoir.
Parce que ce qu’il s’est passé
lorsque vous l’avez vue,
c’est que des photons ont rebondi dessus,
sont venus percuter votre rétine
au fond de votre œil,
qui a envoyé des signaux électriques
jusqu’au fond de votre cerveau,
au niveau du cortex visuel, qui a activé
les neurones de la couleur jaune
de la forme courbe qui, à leur tour,
ont activé les neurones
du concept de la banane.
Ou alors…
Ou alors, un neuroscientifique s’est
branché sur l’une des étapes du circuit
et a activé les bons neurones
au bon moment.
Et vous n'auriez aucun moyen
de faire la différence.
Alors vous vous demandez certainement
comment hacker un cerveau.
Bienvenue dans le petit tutoriel
du Pirate cérébral.
Pour cette démonstration, je vous demande
d’applaudir notre cobaye, Suzanne.
(Applaudissements)
Notre objectif : faire voir
une banane à Suzanne.
Commençons par hacker sa rétine.
La rétine de Suzanne est composée
de cellules qui ont un rôle :
convertir les rayons lumineux
en petites impulsions électriques.
Eh bien, nous allons court-circuiter
ces cellules.
Pour ça, je fais une petite incision
sur le côté de l’œil de Suzanne
et j’y insère 1500 câbles électriques
sur une surface de 3 x 3 mm.
Quand j’envoie une décharge électrique
à droite de la rétine de Suzanne,
elle voit apparaître une tache lumineuse
à gauche de son champ visuel.
Quand j’envoie une décharge électrique
à gauche de la rétine de Suzanne,
elle voit une tache lumineuse
apparaître sur sa droite.
Maintenant, nous allons tenter
de faire voir une banane à Suzanne
en envoyant des décharges électriques
aux bons neurones.
Ce n’est pas de la 4K, mais c’est déjà ça.
Et ce que nous avons accompli
sur la rétine de Suzanne,
on pourrait l’accomplir sur n’importe
quel chaînon du système visuel.
Ou alors, on pourrait tenter
d’activer directement
les neurones du concept de la banane.
Comment les trouver ?
Eh bien, j’insère une électrode
dans la zone du cerveau de Suzanne
qui code les nouvelles mémoires
et je vais enregistrer
l’activité d’un neurone.
L’activité électrique,
je la convertis en son
afin que nous puissions l’écouter.
Et nous allons voir ensemble
si nous avons trouvé
un neurone de la banane.
Pas de réponse.
La tour de Pise.
Roger Federer, fierté suisse.
L’actrice de Friends, Jennifer Aniston.
(crépitement)
Ce crépitement de popcorn
que nous entendons là,
c’est le bruit caractéristique
d’un neurone qui s’excite.
Il semble que nous ayons trouvé
un neurone qui s’excite
lorsqu’il est confronté à des actrices.
Alors,
tentons avec Emma Watson.
Une autre photo de Jennifer Aniston.
(crépitement)
Laissez-moi tenter quelque chose.
Nous avons trouvé un neurone
qui s’active spécifiquement
lorsqu’il est confronté
au concept de Jennifer Aniston.
(Crépitement)
(Rires)
Ce neurone a été découvert
en 2005 chez un patient.
Aujourd’hui, c’est certainement
le neurone le plus célèbre du monde.
Mais revenons à la piraterie.
Il y a fort à parier
que si l’on avait activé les neurones
du concept de Jennifer Anniston
dans le cerveau de Suzanne, elle aurait
subitement pensé à Jennifer Aniston.
Autrement dit, il est conceptuellement
envisageable de pirater les pensées.
Alors, rassurez-vous,
nous n’en sommes pas encore là.
Lorsqu'il s'agit de pirater les systèmes
périphériques, c'est assez facile.
L’ouïe,
le toucher,
la vue ou le mouvement.
Mais lorsqu’on s’aventure
vers les fonctions
les plus complexes du cerveau,
comme les pensées, la réflexion,
la mémoire,
le petit guide du pirate cérébral
devient beaucoup plus flou.
Et pour tout vous avouer, avoir découvert
le neurone de Jennifer Aniston
relève de ce que l’on appelle en science
un gros coup de bol.
Chaque découverte en neurosciences
me confronte à une réalité qui me fascine
et qui m’effraie :
je ne suis qu’une machine.
Chacune de mes sensations,
de mes émotions, de mes pensées
n’est qu’un signal électrique
qui parcourt mes neurones.
Un signal électrique qui peut être piraté,
modifié, effacé.
Il suffit qu’un petit grain
de sable s’immisce dans la machine
pour qu’elle déraille.
Que des neurones meurent
sur le côté de votre cerveau
et vous serez incapable
de reconnaître votre petit-fils.
Que des neurones soient blessés
dans votre moelle épinière,
et vous serez condamné
au fauteuil roulant.
Que des neurones disparaissent
au fond de votre rétine
et vous passerez le restant
de vos jours dans le noir.
Mais il y a une facette excitante
à tout ceci,
c’est que nous sommes des machines
et qu'en tant que machines,
nous pouvons être réparés.
En étudiant et en corrigeant
les circuits cérébraux,
les circuits électriques,
on devient capable de commencer
à prolonger la mémoire
des patients souffrant d’Alzheimer.
Certains patients paralysés réussissent
à remarcher quelques pas.
Certains aveugles récupèrent
une forme de vision.
Alors,
je vous entends dire, Suzanne,
je vous entends penser :
« si c’est pour voir une banane en noir
et blanc en 60 pixels, à quoi bon ? »
Et vous avez raison.
Mais ce n'est que le début.
Toutes ces technologies
n’ont que quelques dizaines d’années.
Aujourd’hui, au moment où nous parlons
dans les laboratoires,
on développe
des implants rétiniens souples,
de minuscules panneaux solaires
qui reçoivent directement
l’énergie de la lumière
et la transforment
en impulsions électriques.
Des yeux bioniques de haute résolution
dont la stimulation est optimisée
par intelligence artificielle.
Des implants capables de distinguer
entre différentes couleurs.
Des milliers de neuroscientifiques
travaillent à découvrir le cerveau
et à inventer
de nouvelles manières de réparer.
Comme eux, je rêve de percer
les mystères de la machine que je suis,
car, pour être honnête, on ne sait pas
encore exactement ce qu’est une banane.
Merci.